but the other news wait this is actually
fantastic I have thought your
congratulations on vacation her
something like I want your life and and
then like I thought you were married
this whole time yes you know what Sarah
no she got engaged I was like to another
party like if she / what you know what
Joel I met Joel like randomly at a book
signing one day one like six years ago
and it was one of those crazy nights
that you're so happy you went out we
started dating and a few years in I all
I was thinking about was having kids and
I couldn't push it away
and when I asked him and I brought this
up I said I can't push it away anymore I
said I have to ask you this important
question though
I said will you explore adoption with me
and literally without blinking without
pausing he looked at me and he said yes
the married part I was like okay well
we're in love we have two kids like who
cares it did matter to him I think a lot
yeah and one day we were at the beach
and it was just the two of us having a
mom and dad trip and he started getting
a lot of mom and dad trips
kela an adult and he was kind of giving
a little a little like love speech which
he does sometimes like I just let's talk
about where we are and I love when he
does that and I was like oh that's so
cute and I had another tequila and was
like looking up and then he was like and
he goes I really have something
important that I'd like to sass and yes
I love all of your talks about love yes
and then he kicked the chair out and he
got on and he was he was crying and I
was crying and I didn't even he goes did
you say yes I said did you ask
but anyway and in that moment I thought
I'd feel like I did the day before
because I already loved him but I had no
idea how profound saying something out
loud is like that telling other people
there's something to that as well
because I was like you I would well
first of all my mom is still shocked
that I'm married and have children I
just didn't think that was gonna happen
but it's just one of those things that
you know didn't matter to me as much
doesn't matter to my husband he had kids
yes you know and he thought I don't know
I think it's important you know and I
was like oh I'm cold and then he'd been
a pop question one day but once it does
happen you're like oh no that is
different it's different than just being
together and in love it's a really cool
declaration in front of everyone and you
know just real like no hell no stay with
my man you know it's a nice thing a ring
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this